Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Welcher Partei traust du zu, die digitale Transformation am erfolgreichsten zu gestalten.
CDU CSU.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer dreihunderteinundneunzig vom neunundzwanzigsten April zwanzig einundzwanzig.
Oder sagt man mittlerweile im Jahre zwei nach der Pandemie oder so? Oder ist es denn das Jahr eins nach der Pandemie.
Haben wir schon eine neue Zeitrechnung? Das ist die eigentliche Frage.
Nee, das Jahr eins nach der Pandemie haben wir noch nicht. So viel ist glaube ich.
Seit der Pandemie, was weiß ich.
Zur Seite.
Seit dem Tag, an dem uns das Virus gebracht wurde.
Virus nicht mehr hören.
Du machst, könnte mal langsam mal ein anderes Thema gebrauchen.
Ja, die können sich echt langsam mal was Neues einfallen lassen.
Das stimmt allerdings, ein bisschen Themenfremd ist das.
Den Wand ganzen Tag Corona, ey.
Ciao. So ist es. Müssen wir mit leben? Haben sozusagen keine andere Wahl.
Jetzt fängst du auch schon an wie der.
Och, wir müssen thematisch mit dem Virus leben.
Aber was ist denn jetzt mit der digitalen Transformation Linus?
CDU CSU.
Ah! Das ist so eine dusselige Umfrage gewesen. Wer wer traut sich denn sowas überhaupt zu fragen, aber wenn man mal genau guckt, also da die meinen, ja die CDU CSU hätte den größten Zuspruch bekommen. Fünfundzwanzig Komma fünf Prozent.
Grüne mit nachts. Ist euer Ernst, aber keiner der genannten hat äh fünfundzwanzig Prozent bekommen. Und der ganze Osten ist irgendwie der Meinung, das kriegt keiner hin.
Und Bayer meint, via dreißig Komma vier Prozent CDU CSU. Könnt ihr euch da sehen.
Also na ja, ich meine, eine also eine grob realistische Einschätzung gibt's ja schon, ne? Nur elf Komma acht Prozent der Befragten halten Deutschland als Wirtschaftsstandort im Bereich der Digitalisierung für wettbewerbsfähig.
So, fragst du dich wo kommen diese elf Komma acht Leute her?
Diese Frage war aber auch echt komisch gestellt hier irgendwie. Welcher Partei mit Regierungsverantwortung auf Landes oder Bundesebene?
Bayern Leute nur für CSU stimmen, weil die Keller gar keine andere Partei mit Regierungsverantwortung. Also ist schon wirklich ein guter Scherz, ne?
Sie haben fünftausendundneunzig Personen. Zwischen dem vierundzwanzigsten Februar und achtundzwanzigsten April befragt.
Repräsentativ für Einwohner Deutschland ab achtzehn.
Ja, haben sie wahrscheinlich übers Internet befragt. Nur nur die Leute erwischt, die auch Internet haben. Also.
Auch sogar hier du bist wirklich, du sitzt da und knallst hier echt,
Schnaps nach dem anderen rein. Die Leiterin von, Janina Mütze erklärte die hohen Kompetenzwerte für die Union damit, dass diese in Umfragen,
immer noch vor den Grünen liege, wenn es um die besten Antworten für die Zukunft gehe.
Das sei eines der wenigen Felder, in denen die Union noch stark sei, Antworten für die Zukunft.
Was.
Denen wurde gerade ihr ihr ähm ihr Klimagesetz weggeklagt von Leuten, die sich um die Zukunft kümmern, ja. Also wie kannst du, wie.
Wie kannst du sagen, so wird die beste Antwort für die Zukunft. Wer konnte in der Zukunft immer am besten begegnen? Ja, CDU, CSU.
Also das ist doch keine Erklärung. Das ist doch einfach nur das ist ja keine Erklärung.
Das ist, das ist ähm das ist äh eine Vergrößerung des Problems, ja? Es ist.
Bärenstark.
Sind die Farbeimer aber auch ganz weit aufgeklappt, ey.
Wir uns nicht erklären aber jede Folge empfehlt uns vielleicht weiter ich würde sagen es gibt da noch Potential,
elf Komma acht Prozent der Deutschen haben uns auf jeden Fall noch nicht gehört, weil die in Deutschland für konkurrenzfähig im Bereich des digitalen halten und ähm,
Ja, die fünfundzwanzig Prozent, die glauben, dass die CDU.
Digitalisierung in Deutschland voranbringt. Hm.
Weißt du, wenn wir jetzt fünfundzwanzig Prozent Deutschlands mit Glasfaser erschlossen hätten, ne, dann könnte ich mir das Ergebnis irgendwie erklären, ne. Aber ist nicht so.
Ist nicht so.
Das macht alles keinen Sinn.
Okay, komm, wir haben heute etwas ausführlicher Feedback.
Und dann schaffe knapp äh äh fassen wir uns bei den Themen etwas kürzer. Äh wir haben ein paar Sachen, sage ich jetzt schon ein bisschen in die nächste Woche eher geschoben. Also Nils K hat Feedback gegeben, weil ich mich gewundert habe, wer denn Jens
ist,
Und ich muss sagen, das haben mir mehrere Leute gesagt, ich habe da Mails bekommen, ich habe Twitter, DMs bekommen. Nils war der Erste, der es kommentiert hat,
der spricht Peter Schau bei den drei Fragezeichen und das bricht mir ja wirklich das Herz, ne,
Weil Tim, weißt du, was du weißt ja, also für dich beginnt ja mein Leben damit, dass ich Podcasts höre, ne. Aber ich hatte ein Leben, bevor ich Podcast gehört habe.
Und ähm Podcasts waren tatsächlich mein Weg aus der Beschaffungskriminalität.
Und das war äh Raubkopien von drei Fragezeichen Hörspielen oder was?
Genau, ich habe alle, ich habe alle Folgen von drei Fragezeichen gehabt, gehabt. So und ähm
Ich habe gehört, gehört, ich habe die nie gehabt. Ähm ich habe ähm ich also
ich habe das auf jeden Fall. Ich habe alle Folgen davon gehört. Und ich bin äh großer Freund davon. Jetzt hätte ich auch echt nicht in dem Video, wenn mir jetzt jemand gesagt hätte, dieser Mensch spricht Peter Schor, hätte ich's jetzt echt nicht erkannt.
Nicht erkannt. Aber ja, finde ich sehr traurig, dass ähm dass es schwieriger Abschied, ja. Aber genau.
Das ist einer von diesen unbekannten äh Schauspielern da oder was?
Genau, ja, ja, ja. Das ist, das ist nicht einer, sondern das ist der, der spezifisch dieses Thema, Applaus von rechts behandelt.
Wo ich ja auch sagte, so, die können einfach nicht behaupten, sie hätten das Ding nicht auf dem Schirm gehabt. Ja, okay, also der ist von drei Fragezeichen. Insofern, ja.
Sind Schauspieler, die Fische. Der Beruf ist, sich zu verstellen. Das kann dann auch manchmal ganz gut funktionieren.
Ja. Also insofern wäre es schön, wenn Justus Jonas den einfach rauswirft. Den, dessen Namen kenne ich, äh oh, jetzt fällt mir natürlich nicht ein. Oliver Rorbeck, glaube ich, es spricht äh Justus Jonas.
Es gibt da einen Oliver Robbeck und ein Andreas Fröhlich. Ich habe äh ich bin noch so alt, ich habe noch die Bücher gelesen, da gab's äh gab's hier irgendwie nicht.
Ja, ja, doch, der ist das. Oliver Robbeck spricht.
Jonas. Aber warte mal, die sind hier abgebildet, doch stimmt. Meine Fresse tatsächlich, da ist auch dieser wahre Check, ja.
Müssen sie jetzt rauswerfen. Kannste machen nix. So, kommen wir weiter zum,
Nein, ich möchte natürlich nicht, dass sie den rauswerfen, aber auch, ich möchte nur deshalb nicht, dass sie den rauswerfen, weil weil sonst irgendwie so eine ähm ähm Märtyrer-Legende da hätten.
Die zwei Fragezeichen und die Märtyrer-Legend.
Kommen wir zur nächsten Thema.
Äh zur nächsten Feedback. Das ist Feedback von Michael.
Oh Mann.
Hallo liebes, hallo Tim.
Ich finde es in eurer Besprechung der Luca-App etwas ungeschickt für die Diskussion, dass ihr die App gemeinsam mit dem und dem Check-In Feature der CWA,
in einen Topf werft. Soweit ich das verstehe, soll sie ein anderes Problem lösen. Während beziehungsweise die Corona waren in Warn-App-Check.
In Funktion. Die Grundfunktion der CWA, das heißt, die anonyme Benachrichtigung von eventuell infizierten,
um die Erfassung von Zusammenkünften erweitern, soll Luca eine einfache und datensparsame technische Lösung für die Erfassung von Gästelisten in Locations bieten, wie sie von den Corona-Schutzverordnungen der Bundesländer gefördert sind
hier nur ein kurzer kurzer Anmerkung äh einfach und datensparsam ist das nicht, ne? Ist ein zentrales System und es sammelt alle Daten in Echtzeit,
Der entscheidende Punkt ist, ähm verschlüsselt. Also es soll nicht einfach und datensparsam sein, sondern es soll verschlüsselt sein, um so zu verhindern, dass alle Personen bezogene Daten auf einem Haufen liegen, ne? Oder auf einem Haufen zugreifbar sind.
So, aber der, das, das wichtige Argument, was äh Michael hier bringt, ist Erfassung von Gästelisten ähm
In Locations. Nee, also nicht an Locations,
ich korrigiere das kurz, Michael, aber du, ich weiß, dass du das Richtige meinst. Erfassung von Gästelisten an, Locations bieten, wie sie von den Corona-Schutzverordnungen der Bundesländer gefordert sind. Das ist der, das ist der wichtige Punkt, den Michael auch vollkommen recht. Ich hatte eigentlich gehofft, wir hätten das ausreichend oft hier auch.
Dargestellt, aber ich lese erstmal noch das Feedback zu Ende vor. Nun kann man natürlich zu Recht darüber diskutieren, ob diese Forderungen in den Verordnungen sinnvoll ist. Dabei kann ich euren Standpunkt mit Blick auf Datenschutz vollkommen nicht vollkommen nachvollziehen. Sehe umgekehrt aber auch Argumente für die namentliche Rückverfolgbarkeit
durch die die durch die Gesundheits äh äh
für die Gesundheitsämter sprechen. Ich würde kurz einen Aspekt sagen, äh ergänzen. Es geht nicht nur um Datenschutz, sondern es geht vor allem ähm
auch um die Schnelligkeit der Alarmierung. Ja, das ist das andere wichtige Argument, aber okay
Ähm Michaels äh Michael macht weiter, gerade dass die Gesundheitsämter eine bindende Quarantäne anordnen können, sehe ich eher als Vorteil, denn wir wissen ja, wie gut das mit der Freiwilligkeit und Selbstverpflichtung in der
Pandemie bisher funktioniert.
Äh in jedem Fall denke ich, dass man die Diskussion über die namentliche Rückverfolgbarkeit von der technischen Umsetzung durch die Luca-App trennen sollte.
Äh für die gegebene Problemstellung scheint mir die App konzeptionell gar nicht so schlecht zu sein. Haben die
direkten Korrekturen eigentlich ein ähnliches
Konkurrenten eigentlich ein ähnliches Verschlüsselungskonzept. Über die katastrophalen handwerklichen Fehler, die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit des Geschäftsmodell und die vielen Millionen Euro versenkte Steuergeld brauchen wir allerdings nicht zu diskutieren. Derzeit, danke fürs Logbuch. Ich habe sehr viel Spaß bei eurem äh Ausführungen,
aufregen beim aufregen über die technischen Fehltritte dieser Welt zuzuhören. Äh danke Michael. Kurze, kurzer äh Punkt.
Glaube tatsächlich, ähm dass du dass dass wichtigste Argument für die Luca-App hier sogar äh äh ausgelassen hast. Die sagen immer, dass sie quasi dadurch ähm.
Hotspots entdecken wollen, ja? Und zwar ähm indem sie sagen, wenn jetzt
in einer Location ganz viele, auf einmal auch positiv sind, dann wissen wir, da war's schlecht. Ja, äh dummerweise können sie daraus natürlich jetzt auch nicht
direkt irgendetwas ableiten, weil alle die da waren, wurden ja eh schon informiert, aber man könnte jetzt irgendwie zum Beispiel vielleicht irgendwann sagen, na ja okay, in schlecht belüfteten Kellern ist es nicht gut. Also dieses dieses Hotspot-Argument geht,
eigentlich so ein bisschen im Kreis, weil aber man weiß es dann, das ist das, was sie immer argumentieren und ich würde ganz klar sagen.
Die namentliche Erfassung durch die äh Gesundheitsämter ist im Sinne der Alarmierung nicht
sinnvoll leer und sie wird auch nicht sinnvoller dadurch, dass die Quarantäne anordnen können, weil sie eben zu langsam sind, dann bringt auch die Quarantäne nichts mehr. Und
eine Quarantäne wird vor allem für Leute angeordnet, die einen positiven Test haben und ähm dann ist es ja auch
gut und wichtig, dass das passiert und dann passiert es ohnehin. Also das Argument, was du hier bringst, ist,
du kriegst 'ne Corona-Warn-App-Warnung, die ist rot und niemand kontrolliert, ob du adäquat darauf reagierst.
Korrektur äh.
Also für Leute, die positiv sind, wird wird keine Quarantäne äh angeordnet, sondern Isolation. Quarantäne ist für die Leute, die vielleicht sich dabei angesteckt haben und wo man,
will, dass sie sozusagen da reinkommen. Ja, das wird äh oft äh verwechselt. Es hat vielleicht an der Stelle aber auch mal ganz wichtig,
zu halten. Und ähm ja, meine im Prinzip spricht er, also,
alles richtig, was du sagst, ja,
verweist aber auch genau auf das Problem. Also klar, diese Luca-App versucht irgendwie, das haben wir ja hier auch schon mal so besprochen, versucht quasi, das, was das Gesetz vorschreibt,
zu implementieren und da mache ich ihn auch erstmal so jetzt keinen Vorwurf, dass sie da versuchen, eine Lösung anzubieten, das haben ja viele andere auch getan, ja? Die konkrete Umsetzung,
Hat halt nochmal zusätzlich ihre Probleme. Dafür kann man sie kritisieren, hast du ja auch gesagt. So. Das aber,
alles letztlich auch gar nichts bringt. Das ist natürlich auch die allgemeine politische Diskussion, die daraus folgen muss. Und wir kritisieren ja vor allem, dass so viel Geld dadrauf äh auf eine für eine Lösung ausgegeben wird, die also einerseits nicht den Standards entspricht,
die wir gerne sehen möchten.
Ja, was Privatsphäre, Datenschutzsicherheit und so weiter äh betrifft. Andererseits muss ohnehin das Gesetz dafür angepasst werden, um das überhaupt zu ermöglichen und dann kann man in dem Moment auch gleich das Gesetz so ändern.
Dass eben die Lösung, die die Corona-Warn-App jetzt in einer sehr viel besseren Implementierung bietet, auch ausreichen würde, weil einfach das Einzige, was uns jetzt wirklich hilft, ist die schnelle Benachrichtigung. Gesundheitsämter haben bewiesen, dass es nicht funktioniert,
Bei solche hohen Inzidenzen.
Und ähm dazu noch ergänzend.
Ähm also ne, ich würde sagen, die die Schnelligkeit der Alarmierung sticht die Möglichkeit, eine Quarantäne zu überwachen
oder anzuordnen, denn wenn man jetzt deinen Gedanken weiterführt, Michael kommt man als nächstes an dem Punkt, dass die Leute sich an die Quarantäneanordnung nicht halten.
Einfach. Das äh und,
dann hast du wiederum nichts gewonnen, beziehungsweise hast dann die Diskussion, dass du als nächstes sagst, jetzt brauchen wir aber die digitale Fußfessel-App, damit die Leute sich daran halten, wir kommen.
Ähm glaube ich, mit diesen Lösungen nur weiter, wenn wir ähm zumindest mal davon ausgehen, dass die Menschen Compliance sind. Und wenn ich wenn jetzt tatsächlich sich rumspräche, übrigens, hör mal, ich habe diese Luca-App gehabt. Äh jetzt habe ich irgendwie eine Quarantäneanordnung bekommen
dann nehme ich nächste Mal lieber.
Ein Laden, wo nicht so ein Luca-Logo dran ist, dann ist auch wieder keinem geholfen. Also, wenn wenn die Dinger wirklich harte Sanktionen haben.
Ähm dann dann tust du dir auch wieder keinen Gefallen. Also mit dieser App kann harte Sanktionen machen kommst du nicht weiter, weil das,
automatisch auch wieder ein Argument gegen die App ist. Ähm hätten wir jetzt alles einfacher sagen können.
Punkt äh Ende vom Lied ist, schnellere Alarmierung ist, glaube ich, wichtiger als Quarantäne-Anordnung. Ähm.
Und Quarantäneanordnung ist auch kein selbst, kein Wert an sich, weil sie nicht
stärker ist als eine gute Information bei einer roten Warnung, weil beides können die Leute vollständig äh umgehen. Und ich muss da auch zugeben, dass ich auch von Fällen weiß, wo das passiert ist, wo Leute ihre
kann Quarantäne gebrochen haben. Also das ist ein Problem, ich würde aber auch sagen, ist kein nicht ein so großes, wie man immer meint.
Weil wir grade in dieser Pandemie auch
immer wieder, weißt du, immer die anderen sind nicht. Ich bin die vernünftige Person, die den ganzen Tag nur alles richtig macht und die anderen da draußen, die Koronisten, die machen den ganzen Tag nur Party. Äh das machen die aber zu Hause, weil weil draußen sehe ich die ja nicht. Also ich glaube, dass wir insgesamt alle mehr
ähm äh also besseren Schutz und bessere Eigenverantwortung wahrnehmen, als vielleicht im Durchschnitt man vermutet.
Okay
der Diktator fühlte sich bemüßigt, sich primär zu unserem, zu unseren Einlassungen, zu äh alles dichtmachen, zu äußern.
Ich lese das jetzt mal so ein bisschen zum diktatorischen Tonfall vor.
Nicht übertreiben.
Nee, nee, nur so. Wann waren die Zustände auf den Intensivstationen schön?
Intensivstation bedeutet Kampf ums Überleben. Jeden Tag sterben im Schnitt zweitausendsechshundert Menschen schon immer,
behaupte einfach, dass keiner dieser Toten schön oder gesund oder glücklich stirbt. Das Problem ist einfach, dass plötzlich eine Betroffenheit in der Welt ist. Keiner.
Der jetzt so aufgeschreckten Gutmenschen hat sich vor Corona um die Patienten auf den Intensivstationen Gedanken gemacht. Keiner um die täglich zweitausendsechshundert Menschen, die schon immer gestorben sind
keiner kümmert sich um die circa fünfzig Toten, die täglich wegen resistenter Keime im Krankenhaus sterben.
Eure ersten Minuten waren Mainstream, rückgradlos, pseudobetroffen und unreif. Bleibt beim Thema Netzpolitik
da kennt ihr euch aus und für dieses Wissen schätzen wir euch. Euer Pseudo Gutmenschentum legt bitte vor
Aufnahme beiseite oder macht vorher einen Podcast, wo ihr diese Themen behandelt. Verseucht aber bitte den LNP-Podcast nicht.
Themenfremder Meinung,
Also jetzt muss ich kurz dazu sagen, ne? Der Tim macht ja schon extra ein pseudo Gutmenschentum Podcast, zur Pandemie mit Pavel.
Aber sowas von Pseudo.
Ja. Also ich äh ich bin äh bin ein bisschen ähm überrascht. Tim, du wolltest da noch was zu sagen?
Also Themen fremd, nehmen wir doch erstmal dieses Wort raus.
Themenfremd, was ist denn Themenfremd? Also wer der Meinung ist oder überhaupt den Eindruck gewonnen hat hier in den letzten Jahren, dass äh das Inhaltsspektrum, dieses Podcast durch zwei Worte Logbuch und Netzpolitik im Titel
ausreichend und umfänglich und abschließend beschrieben ist, hat vermutlich nie richtig zugehört. Wir setzen hier Themen.
Nach Gussow, nach Gefühl, nach
Bauch nach Sachlage vor Ort und nachdem, was unserer Auffassung nach thematisiert gehört
Warum sollten wir sonst einen Podcast machen, wenn wir nicht äh versuchen, diesem Drängen nachzugeben. Netzpolitik ist sicherlich eine wichtige Klammer, aber das ist an sich schon mal auch ein sehr weites Feld. Und natürlich,
kümmern wir uns auch in dem Zusammenhang um die Gesellschaft, weil das ist das, was Politik umfasst,
Politik ist die Gesellschaft. Und das, was in der Gesellschaft passiert, sind politische
Debatten sind politische Vorgänge, sind politische Diskurse und sind äh von daher auch wichtig für alles. Es ist wichtig für
die Entscheidung darüber, mit welchen Gesetzen wir auch mit netzpolitischen Gesetzen wir diesen äh gesellschaftlichen Diskurs begleiten müssen oder auch nicht sollten.
Und so weiter und sofort.
Von irgendetwas anzunehmen, es wäre hier Themen fremd, wenn wir es doch eigentlich hier auch äh aus gutem Grund in den Mittelpunkt ziehen.
Sieht einfach nicht, was dieser Podcast ist.
Ansonsten weiß ich nicht so recht, worüber ich mich äh sonst zuerst noch ähm aufregen soll in diesem Zusammenhang.
Würde inhaltlich dem Kommentar noch entgegnen, äh wenn jeden Tag zweitausendsechshundert Menschen schon immer äh sterben? Ja, ich übernehme die Zahlen jetzt einfach mal so
Ja, ist das eine konstante und die Menschen sterben halt irgendwann, also auch ich werde irgendwann sterben, sehr äh unkomfortabler Gedanke, ja?
An Alter. So, jetzt nimmst du aber hier das Beispiel, wer kümmert sich um die circa fünfzig Toten, die täglich wegen resistenter Keime im Krankenhaus sterben? Auch das ein Problem, haben wir auch kürzlich sogar drüber gesprochen. Ähm wenn
diese Anzahl der fünfzig Toten plötzlich exponentiell ansteigen würde, dann wüsstest du, wie viele Leute sich darum kümmern würden
ja? Das ist das, warum man sich hier gerade äh Gedanken macht und lieber Dictator, das kannst du dir in Indien anschauen. Ähm zur Zeit äh das kannst du dir
aber auch in ähm anderen Ländern anschauen, die an die Grenzen der medizinischen Versorgungsmöglichkeiten kommen.
Tatsächlich ist es so, würde die Anzahl der Coronatoten bei dreihundert konstant bleiben,
Ähm hast du, könntest du dein Argument bringen? Wir erleben aber gerade in einer Gesellschaft, in der wir,
unglaublich aufpassen müssen in einer Situation, in der wir unglaublich aufpassen müssen, dass sich an dieser Zahl nichts,
massiv exponentiell ändert. Und das ist der Kern der ganzen Gesellschaftlichen Debatte, den hättest du hier noch irgendwo mit würdigen müssen.
Ich will auch nochmal dadrauf hinweisen, dass wir keine Pseudo Gutmenschen sind.
Nein, wir sind richtige Gutmenschen.
Sind richtige, richtige, voll ausgewachsene äh geprüfte Gutmenschen.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Und wir machen den ganzen Tag nichts anderes als gegen Schlechtmenschen kämpfen.
So sieht's aus. Und das machen wir sogar ganz gut.
Wahrscheinlich. Ewo.
Sagte dann, ich könnte, na, ich gehe da jetzt nicht mehr drauf ein. Evo, ähm hallo.
Bei Heise heute noch ein interessanter Artikel zur CWA Umfrage digitaler Impfnachweis macht Corona-Warn-App attraktiver,
So, ich ähm möchte den jetzt also, weil der Link so tatsächlich ähm auf diesem Weg kam und ist ja wirklich spannend, ne? Das das finde ich jetzt wirklich auch, ich kann mir nicht, also ich,
Finde es wirklich überraschend ähm äh ich zitiere aus dem verlinkten Artikel, ein digitaler Impfnachweis dürfte laut dem Verband Eco, der die Umfrage gemacht hat.
Zusätzlich zum gelben WHO Impfpass aus Papier. Insgesamt vielen Menschen entgegenkommen
wie eine zweite repräsentative Befragung unter eintausenddrei Menschen in Deutschland ab sechzehn Jahren im Februar ergeben habe. Einundfünfzig Prozent der Teilnehmer wussten demnach spontan
nicht, wo sich ihr entsprechendes Dokument befindet. Achtundvierzig Prozent vielergegen sofort ein Wurst liegt. Ähm,
Einige hatten den Impfpass verloren und daraus.
Sehen sie äh oder daraus leiten sie ab, dass Menschen.
Offenbar sagen, sie hätten gerne einen digitalen Impfausweis. Ich, wie gesagt, bleibe dabei. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob denen klar ist, was es bedeutet, wenn sie den halt noch nicht haben. Aber ähm gleichzeitig sehe ich auch,
vor ein paar Wochen auch mit Thomas da mal drüber gesprochen ähm.
Dass ich dass ich nun tatsächlich auch in Deutschland, heute haben wir, glaube ich, zum ersten Mal eine Millionen geimpft, Menschen am Tag, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe
Das heißt, ähm wenn man jetzt überlegt, wie schnell Deutschland so etwas gebastelt und ausgerollt kriegt, kann es tatsächlich sein, dass wir
an den Punkt kommen, dass die Impfzahlen stagnieren oder sinken, weil wir nicht mehr genug Impfige finden,
und da hatte Thomas ja schon auch das Argument gebracht, dass dann quasi ähm
dass in Aussichtsstellen von Lockerungen beziehungsweise Privilegien, wie ich es nenne, für Geimpfte ähm weitere,
ungeimpfte motivieren könnte, ähm sich vielleicht doch mal kurz in den Arm stechen zu lassen und sich so ungefähr die größte Errungenschaft der Menschheit äh injizieren zu lassen.
Nämlich den Chip von Bill Gates.
Genau. Nein, ich ich nehme den von. Ähm wie heißt der? Tim Apple.
Echt.
So dann außerdem hat Evo noch äh darauf hingewiesen, dass.
Unsere Freunde von PreTex. Äh die ersten waren offenbar die den CWA-Check in mit eingebaut haben.
Also die ist in in die App haben sie die äh Event-Check-Infunktion für die CWA,
äh mit eingebaut, kann für jede Veranstaltung automatisch ein Corona-Warn-App kompatiblen QR-Code generieren. Je nach typischem Besuchsverhalten kann sich dieser entweder täglich ändern oder zu jedem Input hinterlegten
Zeitslot.
Du
Kann ausgedruckt werden oder zum Beispiel auf einem Monitor im Eingangsbereich angezeigt werden.
Genau, du solltest noch kurz erwähnen, was äh ist, also Pritic ist so eine Open-Source äh Software, die,
auch ähm kommerziell betrieben wird, aber komplett äh oder fast komplett äh auch Open Source verfügbar ist, kann man sich also auch selber äh einfach äh nehmen, selber installieren und kostenlos betreiben, um so äh Event
äh Systeme, Zugangssysteme und so weiter damit äh zu machen, funktioniert super, haben wir auch schon mal äh benutzt für unsere Veranstaltung hier.
Immer benutzt bei allen Veranstaltungen haben wir das benutzt.
Genau und ähm
Ja und das äh zeigt auch schön, was so ein guter Standard ein ordentlich gemachte äh Methode da bewirken kann. Es ist halt einfach dokumentiert. Man kann einfach so einen Code äh generieren, der dann automatisch mit dieser CBA kompatibel ist
und das ist irgendwie eine ganz gute ganz gute Geschichte.
Ist auch schön, dass sie das gemacht haben. Ähm Tim, an der Stelle könnte man noch empfehlen. Es ist doch nicht allzu lange her, dass du den Rami in der Freakshow hattest, wie ihr den Rami in der hattet.
Äh sollten wir in den in den verlinken.
Genau, da haben wir sehr ausführlich und lange darüber äh gesprochen, nicht nur, aber sehr viele auch und ja, das war eine ganz gute Sendung. Zweihundertvierundfünfzig Chatroulette Business Edition heißt die.
Okay, dann schrieb äh noch Peter Pool. Ähm wie Linus Neumann von dem Grundrechtsgelaber,
von Heribert Brantel spricht gefällt mir nicht. Über Grundrechte labert man nicht, auch ein Heribert brannte nicht, die Aussage empfinde ich als ungehörig.
Dem würde ich entgegnen. Gelaber wird ja nicht aufgrund des Themas zum Gelaber,
sondern aufgrund seiner Qualität. Und das ist auch das, was ich gesagt habe, dass äh Heribert Brantel
da seiner eigenen Qualität, hinter seiner eigenen Qualität und Möglichkeit zurückbleibt. Nur weil das Thema Grundrechte sind, ist ja nicht automatisch die Qualität der Argumentation gesichert,
Also wir sprechen ja zum Beispiel, glaube ich, in jeder Folge über Grundrechte und ich hoffe, es ist in der Regel kein Gelaber ist. Also, ob etwas Gelaber ist oder nicht, ist vom Inhalt unabhängig.
Heribert Brannte, das war mein Vorwurf. Labert tatsächlich größtenteils einfach nur so vor sich hin,
ohne eben die seinem Niveau und seinem Intellekt angemessenen Gegenvorschläge ähm zu seinen eigenen Kritikpunkten zu etablieren.
Also er sagt, das ist eine Grundrechtseinschränkung. Ja, das wissen wir. Ne, aber die Frage ist ja,
Was ist die Alternative? Wie kommen wir mit weniger Einschränkungen zum Ziel? Und das sind zum Beispiel, wenn ich das ganz kurz arbeiten darf
so Debatten, die wir hier insbesondere im Bereich Daten sammeln und so weiterführen, dass wir sagen, okay, was ist das Ziel? Wie können wir's erreichen? Wie können wir so wenig wie möglich auf den Weg dorthin kaputt schlagen? Und genau das ist die gleiche Frage, muss sich Heribert Brannte
auch stellen, wenn er und es wenn er die ähm ähm gesellschaftlichen Sachverhalte kritisiert, die er kritisiert und ich
sitze da und höre ihn und denke mir, so und jetzt
komm, jetzt sag eben, wie man's hätte besser machen können und das bleibt ihm immer weg. Er sagt nur, das ist eine Grundrechtsanstalt. Das ist eine Grundrechtseinschränkung. Wie so ein Querdenker, der verhaftet wird. Ja, ist eine Schreckung. Ja, ist es, ist es tatsächlich?
Aber es ist halt eine, wo dran steht, dass man das jetzt gerade darf. Und äh das das laste ich Heribert Brantel an, dass er nicht
mit all seinen Ressourcen hier seinem Argument einfach die Stärke gibt, zu sagen, so und so hätte man's besser machen können und deswegen ist das Mist. Und,
der muss sich zum Beispiel mal loben oder mal als Beispiel nennen, äh die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, die wehrt sich gerade gegen die Ausgangssperren.
So, ähm äh kann man lange drüber diskutieren, aber eine Ausgangssperre ganz klar äh Grundrechtseinschränkungen und die sagen nämlich hier so.
Die sind unverhältnismäßig, weil sie nicht auf einem schlüssigen Gesamtkonzept beruhen und weil man im Zweifelsfall andere mildere Mittel hätte.
So und die benennen sie dann auch und dann haben sie Verfassungsbeschwerde und ja, ich halt, ich rechne der als als juristischer Laie irgendwie relativ gute Chancen aus. Immerhin,
tragen sie eine Argumentation vor, äh die, die, die, der ich folgen kann und die vertretbar ist und die eben auch
über Alternativen argumentiert. Und das äh macht Heribert Brannte leider zu wenig.
Das wäre so ein bisschen Feedback äh zu dieser Folge gab es sehr viel Feedback, sehr viel Kommentare und Diskussionen auch zu den äh Schauspielern. Wer sich daran beteiligen möchte, kann das gerne noch tun,
Wer das nicht mehr machen möchte, äh kann dieser Folge was anderes kommentieren. So Tim.
Ja, dann haben wir noch eine eine traurige Nachricht, wie ich finde und das wollte ich an dieser Stelle aber auch noch mal kurz äh erwähnen oder nicht unerwähnt lassen. Und zwar ist gestorben und zwar,
und mag vielleicht vielen von euch erstmal nichts sagen.
Allerdings ist er so in der Hackerszene, Hackerkultur und zwar weltweit. Extrem bekannt, weil er einfach ähm einer dieser,
schillernden Beispiele,
ist für so diese besondere Großartigkeit, die einfach äh meiner Auffassung nach in dieser Szene oft zu finden ist. Also jemand, der einfach technisch extrem kompetent ist
insbesondere äh im Bereich DNS, zu denen Koryphäen gehörte und glaube, sogar irgendwie äh maßgeblich bei.
Der Entwicklung des Ganzen.
Maßgebliche Schwachstellen. Ja.
Und Krypto DNS und so weiter. Also diese ganze äh Technologie extrem vorangebracht hat, also da bahnbrechende äh Sachen gemacht hat, aber einfach auch ein unfassbarer,
Entertainer äh war. Er war.
Großartiger Vortragen da ja.
Großartiger Vortrag, er war mehrere Male auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress, hat den Kongress auch sehr gemocht.
Auch wenn er natürlich so Blackhead und in USA halt vor allem der äh einer der Stars war, aber eben auch oft zu uns gekommen ist und dort immer wieder ganz hervorragende Vorträge gemacht hat.
Hast du wahrscheinlich auch gesehen Linus, ne?
Dass er gestorben ist, habe ich gesehen und ich habe auch Vorträge von ihm gesehen. Ich glaube, der Letzte, den ich gesehen habe, war auf dem achtundzwanzig C drei. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob er danach überhaupt noch mal bei uns war.
Ähm zweitausendfünfundzwanzig C drei achtundzwanzig C drei.
Äh ja, das kann der letzte gewesen sein, wo er bei uns war, genau. Mhm. Black Ops of TCP.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er in Hamburg war oder leiht sich.
Glaube ich auch nicht.
Ja. Gucke gerade noch nur.
Was der Grund ist, weiß ich nicht. Auf jeden Fall äh in, in, in.
Wenn man aus Media CZUS.
Findet man nur achtundzwanzig C drei als als spätestes Ding. Aber diese alten Vorträge sind äh nach wie vor sehr unterhaltsam anzuschauen. Man merkt einfach, was er für eine goldene Gabe hatte,
über seine Themen zu reden, also vor allem sehr sehr unterhaltsam, also lustig, schwungvoll, gut erklärt, jedes Mal eine Show und totales Highlight. Ich habe ihn ähm dann auch mal gebeten,
ähm und habe einen Podcast mit ihm gemacht, damals noch in meiner experimentellen,
reine Chaos, Radio International, das ist so eine Serie von englischsprachigen Interviews, die ich gemacht habe,
findet ihr nicht auf der Meterebene, ist noch auf Chaosradio CCC DE äh archiviert und eine Stunde ein Gespräch,
äh ihm, wo man, glaube ich, ganz guten Einblick bekommt, wie er so denkt über,
und überhaupt äh auch über den Kongress und so weiter und ja, also wenn ihr die Gelegenheit habt, euch äh auf diesem Weg nochmal mit ihm zu beschäftigen, macht das jetzt leider extrem früh gestorben, war jetzt zweiundvierzig,
Komplikationen seiner Zuckerkrankheit und das hat ihn leider dahin gerafft. Sehr schade und äh ja.
So ist es leider.
Ja. Sehr traurig und ähm sollten wir in guter Erinnerung und als Vorbild behalten.
Um euch gleich wieder auf Laune zu bringen, ist noch eine andere Story irgendwie ausgegraben, die die Story fand ich wirklich super. Und zwar gab's
eine Frau in äh Texas, die hat irgendwie geheiratet, woraufhin sich ihr Name geändert hat und dann ist sie irgendwie zum Amt gegangen, hat gesagt, so, Jörg, bitte mach mal den neuen Namen bitte am Führerschein äh eintragen,
immer so bürokratische Prozesse nach sich zieht, da stellt sie sich raus, dass gegen sie eine vorliegt und zwar schon seit einundzwanzig Jahren.
Wovon sie keine Ahnung hatte, aber in dem Moment kam's irgendwie raus.
Und äh auf die Frage, warum denn bitte äh äh das? Und worum's denn davon nichts äh wüsste. Ja, sie hätte eine Videokassette ausgedient bei einer Videothek, so eine VHS-Kassette und nicht wieder zurückgebracht.
Und daraufhin ist wohl gegen sie Anzeige äh erstattet worden.
Weil irgendwie eine Folge von äh Sabrina The Teenatwitch äh sozusagen nicht wieder zurückkam. Diese Videothek gibt's natürlich nicht mehr, weil,
Gibt keine Videotheken äh mehr, also zumindest nicht in USA. Hier gibt's komischerweise noch welche. Ich habe ich habe hier um die Ecke tatsächlich doch so eine Videothek und frag mich immer wieder, was.
Warum, wie? Egal, ne? Und dann, na ja, dann kam also diese ganze Story raus und meinte, ja, das hätte sich auch irgendwie schon gewundert, warum sie so in den letzten Jahren immer äh häufiger von ihren Jobs einfach so gekündigt wurde und nie so genau wusste, warum eigentlich.
Oh Mann.
Und das ist halt so eine Story, ähm.
Also sie meinte so die wüsste gar nichts von dieser Videokassette und das was weiß ich, haben vielleicht ihre Kinder ausgeliehen oder keine Ahnung. Äh das wird wahrscheinlich nie geklärt werden, weil wie gesagt, diese Video äh Theke Kette überhaupt nicht mehr gibt, war wahrscheinlich
weiß nicht ganz genau,
Und ähm trotz alledem sind halt diese Records da, worum's nie wirklich jetzt zu einer Verhaftung kam. Weiß ich nicht, aber die Unternehmen, die sie beschäftigt haben, die konnten dann halt solche Backgroundchecks machen und kriegten dann halt irgendwie so eine Meldung mit so, ja, hier und so weiter,
diese halbautomatisierten Human Resource Departments wahrscheinlich einfach gesagt haben, die Frau sowieso.
Nicht, dass ihr irgendjemand sagt, warum. Hm?
Fand ich mal wieder eine sehr bemerkenswerte Story, die äh schön zeigt, was so The Power of Data im Hintergrund ist und Auskunftssysteme, die nicht äh öffentlich und transparent agieren oder der notwendigen Kontrolle
unterliegen oder zumindest regelmäßig immer mal wieder geordnet werden oder,
auch die die Inhalte überprüft werden, ob sie überhaupt stimmen. Und wie die Polizei jemanden einundzwanzig Jahre lang suchen könnte, wahrscheinlich problemlos aufzufinden ist, ist mir dann nochmal ein ganz anderes Rätsel,
Also mal schön aufpassen, immer schön Videokassetten zurückbringen, ihr wisst Bescheid.
Ja. Also, ich meine, wie die wird auch jetzt schwer zu bekommen sein, ne, wenn sie die jetzt noch schuldet, also.
Das Ding wurde mittlerweile dann aufgehoben. Das haben sie dann irgendwie eingetütet.
Okay.
Linus, wir haben schon so lange, so lange nicht mehr über die Luca-App gesprochen. Bestimmt schon eine Woche oder so.
Ja, wir wir haben es ja beim letzten Mal schon gesagt, wir wollen zum letzten Mal drüber gesprochen haben.
Ja, das wird, glaube ich, nix.
Also es wird äh ich ich möchte wir machen heute nur eine Luca News zwei. Und ähm
Ansonsten, aber die halten wir auch kurz
Weil das Thema hängt mir, glaube ich, echt inzwischen einfach zum Halse raus und ich muss mir noch ein bisschen Motivation äh erhalten darüber zu sprechen, weil ich das am nächsten Mittwoch im Ausschuss Digitale Agenda des Bundestags nochmal machen muss.
Ähm und heute ist aber erschienen. Das finde ich sehr bemerkenswert, eine
gemeinsame Stellungnahme zur digitalen Kontaktverfolgung von siebenundsiebzig Professorinnen, Professorinnen und Mitgliedern der akademischen Forschung ähm.
Die äh Luka kritisiert. Ja, ähm und das ich,
ne, sie haben einfach mal gesagt, sie haben nämlich vor letztes Jahr, als es um die äh CWA-Debatte ging, einen offenen Brief an Regierungen geschrieben und äh appelliert Technologien zur digitalen
Kontaktverfolgung, Verantwortung und zielgerichtet zu entwickeln, wurden Prinzipien gefordert, nämlich die Zweckbindung,
Offenheit und Transparenz, die Freiwilligkeit und eine sinnvolle Risikoabwägung.
Ja? Und sie sagen, attestieren auch der CWA, dass die größtenteils vorbildlich umgesetzt wurden. Bei der Zweckbindung geht's eben darum, ne, sollen nur diesem einen Zweck dienen
und sollte dann eben auch äh sich im Prinzip erledigt haben. Das hatte ich ja auch gesagt, die Corona-Warn-App ist im Prinzip gebaut zum Aussterben,
ja? Ähm einigen von euch wird sicherlich auffallen, dass die euch auch regelmäßig dran erinnert oder euer,
iPhone oder Android-Telefon erinnert euch daran, dass das noch aktiv ist und ob ihr es noch braucht
und Apple und Google haben auch angekündigt, dass sie diese Notification Framework Funktionalität regional ausschalten werden, wenn man sie nicht mehr braucht, ne? Also
keinerlei Möglichkeit für ein Geschäftsmodell nach der Pandemie äh Offenheit und äh Transparenz, ne, dass also äh.
Eben zum Beispiel der die Akademie sich konstruktiv am Entwicklungsprozess
beteiligen kann und den unabhängig begutachten kann, freiwillige Nutzung und Risikoabwägung. Das ist ja der der wichtige Punkt, den wir
eben auch nennen, die Beurteilung des Nutzens und der Risiken einer Lösung müssen im Vorfeld unabhängig und öffentlich geprüft werden können. Und jetzt kommen Sie also zu dem Schluss, dass das bei der Luca-App,
nicht der Fall ist. Keines dieser vier Prinzipien ist erfüllt. Ähm das bereits in vielen Bundesländern eingesetzte Lukas-System erfüllt keine dieser Prinzipien.
Ähm und sie kommen zu dem Fazit, wir empfehlen eindringlich die
Besinnung auf die umbenannten Prinzipien und deren Anwendung bei der Entwicklung digitaler Werkzeuge zur Kontaktnachverfolgung. Insbesondere sollte aus unserer Sicht keinen de facto Zwang zur Nutzung einer Lösung geben, die diese Prinzipien
eklatant verletzt. Um das Thema Zwang, da werden sie wahrscheinlich um die Diskussion
aus den Diskussionen gelernt haben, dass sie eben sagen, es ist ein de facto Zwang, wenn halt ne Länder so und so viel Geld investieren und in ihren Verordnungen drinstehen haben, macht das mal damit, dann ist es halt
letztendlich etwas, was den Menschen keine andere
informierte Wahl mehr übrig lässt. Ich fühle mich natürlich auch äh geehrt, dass sie die Stellungnahme des CCC unter ihren Referenzen haben, viele andere, äh die sie da auch drin haben und dann
jetzt kommen wir mal dazu, die Erstunterzeichnenden, ne? Unter, das sind alles Leute mit Professoren bis auf einige wenige, wo ich sagen würde
die sind wirklich auf dem besten Weg, diesen Professorin bei zu haben
ja? Äh das ist sind einfach noch äh einfach dem Alter geschuldet, weil die paar Leute, die kriegen ja auch fast alle und da sind jetzt so ich ich lese jetzt mal nur so ein paar vor und ich weiß, da werden sich jetzt einige auch übergangen fühlen
Wir reden hier von siebenundsiebzig Namen, die kann ich nicht alle nennen, ne? Aber vielleicht mal so die Affirdiation.
Dort Professor Doktor Florian Alt, Universität der Bundeswehr München. Ähm
Michael Backes, Sispa Helmholtz Center for Information Security ist der Leiter dort. Äh Markus Bläser Universität des Saarlandes, Erik Bonn Heinz Nicksdorf-Institut der Universität Potsdam. Universitätspotsdam, da gibt's ja auch das HPI,
Institut sogar vom HPI gibt es Unterzeichnende, ja? Also das sind ja da kommen ja diese äh Leute her, ja? Ähm,
Du liest hier äh Namen, ne, also sehr viel CISPA, das äh Gabi, Dreh Rodosek, äh äh Bundeswehruniversität, äh also dieses Forschungsinstitut Code Hannes Federer
ja? Ähm das ist der, also hier in seiner Rolle als Professor an der Universität Hamburg, ist aber auch der ähm Präsident der Gesellschaft für Informatik
ja? Also hier ist hast du wirklich alle. Äh seeadöses äh von der TÜD ähm also ich bitte,
Tibor Yaga, bitte sehen Sie es mir nach, dass ich jetzt nicht alle benenne, aber ich kann auf jeden Fall sagen, wir fallen jetzt wirklich kaum Leute ein, ähm
die das nicht unterzeichnet haben unter den ersten Unterzeichnenden und dann gibt's ja auch noch die weiteren Unterzeichnenden und da sind jetzt auch schon wieder dreihundert dazugekommen.
Und so läuft das eben, ne? Also da da ist dann jetzt, bin ich auch relativ
ist ja für mich auch eine persönliche Erleichterung so, weil es ja zwischendurch auch sehr ähm ja,
bösartige Angriffe oder Vorwürfe von Seiten Culture for Life gegen den Chaos-Computerclub gab, ne, wir würden da irgendwie eine Partikularmeinung vertreten. Das sollte sich dann jetzt auch wirklich erledigt haben. Ne, also das ist,
Ja, das äh kann man sich mal durchlesen, finde ich sehr spannend und ähm ich denke, da sollte man sich auch äh viel mehr drauf beziehen, als das bisher ähm ähm mediale Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat.
Ja, das ist schon ziemlich vernichtend.
Ja, also das sind wirklich mal äh also da das das sind die das ist die akademische Forschung,
der im Bereich der des Datenschutzes und der IT-Sicherheit und ähm,
ich kann auch gewissermaßen verstehen, dass sie sich da so zu melden. Das ist ja, muss man ja auch sagen, ein seltener Schritt, dass sich die Akademier in so einer Zusammen,
in so einer fortgeschrittenen Auseinandersetzung zu Wort meldet, insbesondere, wenn es jetzt um ein spezifisches Produkt geht, ne? Ähm die haben sich davor.
Bei der Spezifikation gemeldet, als um die Corona-Warn-App ging, ne? Und es ist auch ein ähm.
Einmaliger Vorgang, dass die halt so ignoriert wurden.
Ich kann mich da an gar nichts erinnern, wo das schon mal stattgefunden hat.
Ja ja doch, doch, doch, die haben, das hatte ich ja gerade. Also, ja, weil ich ja gerade schon gesagt, die haben ein äh damals gab es diese Debatte noch um zentral dezentral und da haben die sich genauso wie der CCC äh auch auch zu Wort gemeldet. Ganz klar,
Ja, natürlich. Ist so. Und ähm.
Ne, dass die natürlich ihre Prinzipien benennen und wofür unterhalten wir uns denn alle diese
muss ich auch sagen, dass die andere Sache, die ich daran so spannend finde, dass dir da mal so einfällt so, ja man denkt immer so, hier in der Ruhruniversität
Bochum, ne, da weiß man, das ist irgendwie da auch mehrere Professoren von der Ruhr Universität Bochum dabei. Das ist so eine der bekannten IT-Security, ne, da hast du Darmstadt, ähm,
Torsten Holz natürlich eine Universität Bochum und so weiter. München, aber das ist dann auch mal siehst du, okay krass, wir haben vielleicht doch eigentlich in Deutschland so was wie eine,
ähm wirklich respektable IT-Security-Community,
die müssen da halt auch einfach mal alle so ein, so ein Brief unterschreiben, damit man die Namen mal alle hat. Ja, finde ich schon sehr ähm.
Sehr beeindruckend und sehr schön. Kann auch verstehen, dass sich diese
Millionen von Euro jedes Jahr, ne, aus öffentlichen Geldern ähm und äh Drittmitteln finanzierten
öffentlichen Forschungseinrichtungen, dass sie dann eben auch sagen so, na ja, wäre schon schön, wenn wenn das, was das Wissen, was wir hier aufschreiben und die Forschung, die wir betreiben, vielleicht auch irgendwo, dass die Gesellschafter auch von partizipieren und profitieren können.
Ja, insofern finde ich das eine naturgemäß sehr äh sehr bemerkenswert und äh sehr äh erfreulich.
Dann gab es noch einen Fall, ich weiß nicht, hatten wir eigentlich Ralf Rottmann hier schon mal erwähnt, ja, ne?
Ich glaube nicht ähm
Auch neulich übrigens äh zu Gast. Da ging's aber um was ganz anderes. Ähm nein, aber Ralf äh hat auf jeden Fall auch eine Menge Spaß mit der Luca-App in den letzten
Wochen, das kann man nicht anders sagen, hat sich da aus verschiedenen Gründen das Thema ganz gut reingebissen und äh ja, bleibt dran.
Und findet auch immer wieder lustige Sachen raus, unter anderem, dass äh ja
das das ist sozusagen diese App auch Verwendung, findet an Orten, wo es eigentlich gar nicht sein könnte.
Der hat ein Brillengeschäft äh in Dortmund entdeckt,
äh wo man wo die Kunden und Kunden und Kunden mit der Luca App einchecken müssen. Aber in Dortmund sind die Gesundheitsämter noch gar nicht an die App angeschlossen.
Und ist natürlich dann hat er die angetwittert, hat gesagt, hier wie kommt ihr denn damit euer gesetzlichen Pflicht nach, diese äh Daten zu sammeln.
Und das haben die dann irgendwie längere Zeit ignoriert und ähm dann passierte Folgendes, ähm.
Er twitterte dann,
Ja, also sie hätten's jetzt irgendwie endlich abgeschaltet, das könnte aber damit zu tun haben, dass er da äh jeden Tag fünfhundert Leute eingecheckt hat. Die, die dann nämlich manuell wieder auschecken müssen. Was ja bei der Luca App geht. Wir haben das ja äh äh
genug,
ich wiederhole das nur nochmal bevor es wieder heißt ja das geht beim Zettel auch, ja beim Zettel kannst du auch falsche Daten draufschreiben, weil du kannst nicht auf einen zentralen Zettel in der Mitte des Internets in jeder Location ein, alle möglichen Daten reinschreiben
und ja, Ralf hat sich jetzt irgendwie auf Twitter halt dazu bekannt, dass es damit zu tun haben könnte.
Dass er da halt äh viele hundert Leute jeweils eingecheckt hat. Darauf wurde er dann,
von von dem ähm von Patrick Hennig ähm kommentiert
Du bist halt so ein richtig starker Typ, Glückwunsch für deine tolle gesellschaftliche Verantwortung. Und da stellt man sich ja schon die Frage, ich meine, wo fängt denn die gesellschaftliche Verantwortung
an, wenn ich einen Laden diese App benutzen lasse, dessen Gesundheitsamt noch gar nicht angeschlossen ist. Oder wenn Ralph Rottmann dann da hingeht und sagt, ich ich gehe mal hin und nochmal und nochmal und nochmal. Also,
ich finde es ehrlich gesagt, das finde ich tatsächlich ein Problem, wenn die Luca-App-Locations mit dem falschen Glauben anwirbt, sie würden Daten sammeln, die ihr Gesundheitsamt entschlüsseln könnte
Ähm ich möchte aber auch gleich dazu sagen, warum äh die Luca-App das macht oder machen kann,
Oder meint, machen zu können, das ist nämlich, weil die natürlich theoretisch, Gesundheitsämter nachher anschließen können und ähm denen quasi äh den Key noch irgendwie zukommen lassen können
der da vorher schon irgendwie wirkt, ja? Und ähm das ist natürlich auch das ist so typisches Start-up-Denken, ne.
Voll geil, wenn wir doch schon Nachfrage bei den Kunden haben, lass uns doch den Druck auf die Locations nutzen, wenn die Locations mitmachen, lasst
lass uns doch den Druck auf die Gesundheitsämter nutzen und so ähm
man kann das System schneller wachsen, aber natürlich müsste man sicherstellen, dass das Versprechen, was dieser Check-In macht, natürlich dann auch eingehalten werden kann. Und sicherlich würden sie darauf entgegnen, dass sie den
äh auch posthock einhalten können, wenn das Gesundheitsamt Dortmund endlich angeschlossen ist. Und ich würde entgegnen, ja, man sollte aber eigentlich, ehrlich gesagt, erst mit den Daten für das Gesundheitsamt sammeln. Anfangen, wenn das Gesundheitsamt die auch empfangen,
vielleicht möchten die das ja auch nicht.
Vielleicht ist das ja auch am Ende alles gar nicht so wichtig.
Ja, vielleicht tatsächlich, ich das ist ja der andere Gag, äh ich würde ja immer sagen, das ist nicht so wichtig, weil das Gesundheitsamt für die Daten eh nicht haben, insofern könnte man auch sagen, der ist schon ganz okay so.
Aber komm, lassen wir lassen wir diesen Luka. Wir haben was ganz anderes. In Rheinland-Pfalz Tim, wir haben ein riesen Problem in Rheinland-Pfalz, unsere Bitcoins sind weg.
Unsere.
Ja, äh also äh also die waren, die gehörten ja zumindest Rheinland-Pfalz.
Du meinst die Kohle, die sie sozusagen beschlagnahmt haben?
Ein ein ja genau, die ja, das ist das ist auch ähm das ist wirklich sehr schön, also ähm.
Das Einmaleins in Sachen Bitcoins,
ja? Also es gibt eine alte Weisheit, die hier zitiert wird. Äh also wenn dir nicht die Schlüsse gehören, sind es auch nicht deine,
Coins, ja? Denn das Ganze, diese ganzen Bitcoins, das ist ja auch das das Faszinierende daran, dass es ergibt ja sehr viel mehr Leute, die mit Bitcoin
Traden und Handeln und meinen damit reich werden zu können oder vielleicht auch damit reich geworden sind als Menschen, die wirklich verstehen, wie Bitcoin funktioniert
und nur ein Bruchteil der Leute, die mit Bitcoins rumfuchteln, sind die, die wirklich wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Und äh um es kurz zu machen, ne, also Krypto heißt das deshalb, weil man bestimmte Schlüsselmaterial braucht, um über seinen äh Wallet zu verfügen. Und,
ähm wenn man diese Schlüsselmaterial hat, dann kann man über sein Geld verfügen und wenn man das Schlüsselmaterial nicht mehr hat, ähm dann kann man
darüber nicht verfügen. Das ist ja der Grund, warum's dann so Leute gibt, die einen Kredit wollen, um eine Müllkippe zu kaufen, um ihre alte Bitcoin-Festplatte da drin zu finden, um die Daten wieder herzustellen und dann der reichste Mann der Welt zu sein.
Ähm.
Sonne,
und äh jetzt hätte halt die Rheinland-Fälsche Rheinland-Pfälzische Justiz ein Bitcoin Wallet beschlagnahmt ähm von einem,
Darknet äh Drogenmarktplatz namens Chemical Love und,
da waren siebenhundertsiebenundfünfzig Bitcoins drauf,
hier steht jetzt Tageskurs drei Komma sechs Millionen Euro. Dreiunddreißig Komma sechs Millionen Euro.
Hätte ich jetzt mehr gedacht.
Siebenhundertsiebenundfünfzig.
Noch viel mehr sein, oder?
Dreiunddreißig Komma zwei Millionen Euro sind das gerade so.
Ah ja okay, dann haben die Angreifer jetzt schon wieder vierhundert vierhunderttausend Euro verloren durch Kursschwankungen. Okay, dreiunddreißig Millionen Euro, ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz amtlich. Ähm und da haben sie halt.
Das Wallet ähm äh beschlagnahmt und das Wallet befand sich auf Hardware. Ja, und da ist aber jetzt nicht genau, also hier in dem Artikel ist nicht so genau beschrieben, wahrscheinlich also mit Hardware, meinen sie wahrscheinlich Computer. Und ähm.
Die Justiz konnte aber nicht auf ihrem Bitcoinschatz zugreifen, denn das Volleyball Passwort geschützt verschlüsselt.
Die haben dann versucht, das zu entschlüsseln und das aber fehlgeschlagen. So, jetzt.
Ist halt die Frage, was ist so ein Wallet? Also ich würde jetzt davon ausgehen, ist ein letztendlich eine Datei
Ne, man kann, es gibt auch sicherere Aufbewahrungsmöglichkeiten für Wallets, aber hier würde ich jetzt mal davon ausgehen, dass es eine Datei ist und solange das Wallet als Datei vorliegt und auch der Secret Kieder drin, als Datei vorliegt, dann
besteht natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit das zu kopieren.
Und äh diese verschlüsselte äh Wallet,
nur weil du eine verschlüsselte Wallet heißt, hast, heißt das ja nicht, dass es nicht eine Kopie davon gibt oder irgendjemand anders in der Lage ist, das gleiche Schlüsselmaterial auch äh wieder herzustellen.
Und das scheint hier passiert zu sein, denn von dieser Wallet, die sie da sich im Schrank liegen hatten, ähm wurden.
Ähm jetzt Bitcoins transferiert ins in mehreren und jetzt sind sie halt weg. Also am ersten März,
wurden zweihundertvierundsechzig Bitcoin wegtransferiert zwanzig siebzehn sogar schon. Erster März zwanzig siebzehn und Ende zwanzig neunzehn nochmal vierhundertneunundachtzig Bitcoin,
Damit ist der größere Teil dieses Geldes eben weg. Es wird jetzt spekuliert, dass der
verurteilte vielleicht eine terministische Wallet-Anwendung genutzt hat. Äh das ist das, dass du quasi einen kryptographischen aus dem du das wieder errechnen kannst. Da hast du eine Reihe, also
eine emonische Passe, wo du einfach eine Reihe an Wörtern hast, die typischerweise durch so einen Bindestrich getrennt werden und
Damit kannst du, den kannst du dir merken.
Bist dauert ein bisschen, weil's viele Worte sind, aber es könnte jetzt zum Beispiel sein, dass dieser Verurteilte sich das gemerkt hat und ähm vielleicht diese Wörter einem irgendwie aus dem Gefängnis rausgeschmuggelt hat. Ähm.
Kann auch, was weiß ich, ausgedruckt haben oder was auch immer. Auf jeden Fall, die Kohle ist jetzt abgewandert und der gute Mann hat natürlich auch eigentlich Prosable, die Nineability, allerdings, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, wurde der zu fünfzehn Jahren äh verurteilt,
stellt sich also vielleicht auch für ihn die Frage wie der Bitcoin-Kurs dann ist.
Na ja gut, ich meine kannst natürlich äh
im Garten vergraben. So oder vergraben lassen von irgendjemand, aber ob er nach fünfzehn Jahren da noch äh die
dieselben Leute antrifft, ist natürlich eine andere Frage. Aber es muss ja nicht diese Person sein. Es kann ja auch irgendjemand in der Justiz gewesen sein, der da mal so eine kleine äh Kopie angelegt hat.
Äh ja, aber wie gesagt, also ich müsste jetzt mal ausrechnen, ob ähm dreiunddreißig Millionen, ja, kommt so ein bisschen drauf an, wie lange die Passphase ist, ne?
Also für dreiunddreißig Millionen Euro würde ich mich richtig anstrengen.
Ja, ja.
Da kann ich mir einiges merken. Da da fragen sich die Kinder immer, wozu muss ich in der Schule lange Gedichte auswendig lernen?
Dafür lohnt sich das.
So, dann dann wurde wieder das ist aber nicht das einzige Geld, was wir verbraten haben. Was was vernichtet wurde. Das Geld ist ja, ist ja nicht vernichtet. Es ist ja nur woanders.
Und äh die hundert Millionen US-Dollar an Investorenkapital, die in Augustus Intelligence versenkt wurden, sind auch weg,
die haben sich verwandelt in zwei Millionen Dollar Schulden. Warum ist das interessant.
Weil äh dass der Laden ist für den Philipp Abendtor der Bundestagsabgeordnete Philipp Amthor Lobbyarbeit gemacht hat. Äh und davon persönlich profitiert hat. Er hat ja dann seine Anteile,
Ähm zurückgegeben, aber die sind jetzt auch äh nur in der Konkurrenzmasse, ne.
Also am Tor als
Lobbyist, was ja auch so witzig ist, ey, du bist Bundestagsabgeordneter und arbeitest nebenbei als Lobbyist. Das wird dann Lobbyismus genannt und nicht Korruption, ne. Das finde ich total witzig. Ähm auf jeden Fall
dir der Laden ist pleite.
Ist gut gelaufen, ne. Könnte man natürlich sagen, na ja, er durfte ja auch nicht mehr weiter lobbyieren, dann äh kann er es halt auch nicht funktionieren. Siehst du mal, was so ein Bundestagsabgeordneter wert sein kann?
Oh je.
Fand ich, finde ich auf jeden Fall, na ja, was hast du schon erwartet? Ich meine, natürlich, das war doch einfach nur, ich meine, die Bude hat jetzt, die wurde jetzt geplündert und fertig ist
vor allem das war ja auch allen klar, das das war ja schon absehbar, ne, als dieses Thema groß war, wurde ja auch gesagt, so dieses Unternehmen hat kein Produkt, dieses Unternehmen hat einen Angestellten
und äh und und im Briefkasten oder sowas, ne. Und keine Kunden.
Nicht überall, wo Intelligenz draufsteht, ist auch Intelligenz drin. Das sollte man sich merken.
Das ist richtig.
So, dann können wir jetzt mal noch kurz ein Thema einleiten, was uns sicherlich die nächste Zeit ähm begleiten wird. Und zwar sind das so diese
Ich würde sagen, allgemein Privacy-Kämpfe, die jetzt so in die nächste Runde gehen.
Apple hat ja jetzt kürzlich ein relativ starke Kampfansage gegen,
Tracking in Apps gemacht. Was war da denn genau los, Tim?
Ja, es gibt jetzt ein Update für iOS,
das Eiweiß vierzehn Punkt fünf Update, wo Apple, ein Feature freigeschaltet hat, was sie schon längere Zeit angekündigt haben. Ich glaube, das ist sogar von der letzten Developer Konferenz, also fast schon ein Jahr her. Ähm.
App-Tracking, äh wie ist das noch gleich? AT, was gerade nicht genau sich.
App-Tracking Transparency wahrscheinlich.
Ja, genau, das war's. Und im Kern ist das das Ausschalten eines Features, äh was es Apps bisher erlaubt hat, so app-Übergreifend quasi Aktivität zusammenzutragen unter so einer Werbe-ID
warum es das überhaupt jemals gegeben hat, ähm dass ich mal außen vor, aber umso besser, dass man's jetzt abschalten kann, äh wenn man das grundsätzlich ähm noch erlaubt, dann wird zumindest bei jeder App erstmal gefragt.
Darf, aber man kann's auch so global ausschalten und das verhagelt so diversen Firmen im Smartphonebereich äh besonders auf diesem
iPhone Markt, wo er sich einfach mehr Leute tummeln, die viel Geld ausgeben im Netz, so ein bisschen die die bisherige Strategie. Und grundsätzlich sieht man ja auch an anderen Stellen,
das einfach äh in zunehmenden Maße einfach ein Verkaufsargument wird. Das ist einfach rüstet sich so langsam zu so einem gefragten,
Leute achten dadrauf, die Awareness für die eigene Privatsphäre, die steigt,
und so langsam sehen die Firmen, die halt ihr ganzes Business darauf basieren und das ist vor allem natürlich Facebook und und eben auch
Google so ein bisschen die Fälle davon schwimmen und versuchen auch schon mal neue Technologien oder neue Ansätze äh in Stellung zu bringen, um halt so
einer etwas äh restriktiveren Datenpolicy im Betriebssystem äh ein ja etwas entgegensetzen zu können.
Hm, ich also es ist halt es, also ich wenn man mal jetzt irgendwie
Privacy als als Markt äh Wert vorwegnimmt, kann man's natürlich auch einfach mal so ein
Plattformkampf sehen, ne. Also Apple weiß einfach so, wir verkaufen
Geräte zu so guten Preisen und wir äh brauchen dieses User-Tracking nicht, ne? Das macht tatsächlich so, dass sie das nicht ähm betreiben, dass sie halt auch vor allem wissen, so vor allem können wir das,
die anderen Plattformen, die das so gut machen
sehr sehr schön von unserer Plattform oder in diesen Bereich einhängen. Ähm das war ja sogar so, dass ich glaube, da hat Facebook doch sogar eine einseitige Anzeige geschaltet, dass das Apple jetzt das offene Web,
äh killen würde mit.
Ja ja.
Und so, ne?
Also das waren war ein riesiger Kampf und es kommt auch ein anderer an einer anderen Stelle gibt es so ein ähnliches,
Problem und das ist so diese Party-Cookies. Da hat Apple nämlich also auch, das ist aber jetzt nicht irgendwie ein Kampf, den nur Apple voranbringt, ähm sondern auch sehr viele Browser Plug-Ins und die Browser werden da auch immer besser. Ähm,
Aber Apple hat ja irgendwann angefangen zu sagen, hör mal, diese ganzen, alles, was wir fürn Tracking-Cookie halten, ähm,
das werfen wir eh einfach nach einer Zeit wieder weg und randomisieren die einfach nach unserer Laune durcheinander. Und ähm das.
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche, zur Folge, dass ich mit einem Apple Browser andauernd wieder dieses, ich möchte was weiß ich, Spiegel der Zeit online ohne Werbung sehen,
Feld klicken muss. Was mit anderen Browsern glaube ich nicht so ist, aber das ist jetzt eine reine Spekulation.
Schon sein, ich sehe das oft und ich benutze halt äh in der Regel Safari.
Und will sagen, der Sir Party-Cookie,
der stirbt. Und der führt war im Prinzip, du gehst auf eine Seite und die lädt außerdem noch Inhalte von einer anderen Seite und diese andere Seite gibt dir einen Cookie und wenn du die Seite,
Wiedereingebunden hast in einer dritten Seite, ja
dann erkennt die dich wieder, weil du dich nämlich automatisch mit dem Cookie wieder dort meldest. Cookies sind nichts anderes, als dass dir der Webserver sagt übrigens, ich gebe dir mal hier dieses Stück Information und wenn du das nächste Mal hier wieder antanzt mit deinem nächsten Rickfest, sendest du das bitte wieder mit
Ist eine fundamental Basisfunktion ähm zum Beispiel damit so eine Seite auch unterscheiden kann, dass du eingeloggt bist, ne, wenn jetzt irgendwie der Tim sich im Backend von Logbuch Netzpolitik
anmeldet, dann hat sein Browser einen Cookie. Und bei jedem Mal, wenn er sich dorthin verbindet.
Sendet der Browser diesen Cookie mit und deswegen weiß die der der Server, ach guck mal hier, der Cookie, das ist der Tim
der ist eingeloggt. Der darf jetzt hier zum Beispiel, ne, eine neue Episode veröffentlichen und ähm ich habe einen anderen Cookie und jemand, der nicht eingeloggt ist, hat keinen
Und daran, also es ist eine Fundamentalfunktion, weil du aber diese Information immer wieder mitsendest, eignet sie sich eben auch enorm gut für Tracking. Und jetzt
stirbt langsam, ne? Es wird in dem Browser irgendwie äh immer mehr zur Standardfunktion vielleicht äh einfach direkt wegzuwerfen. Es gibt eine Reihe an Plug-ins dagegen.
Apple hat in ihre Browser schon Basisfunktionalitäten um die abzuschütteln und das ist.
Ganz gut. Ja, dass das Cookie jetzt so langsam stirbt. Und gleichzeitig muss ich aber natürlich ähm,
so ein Unternehmen wie Google überlegen, hm was ist denn eigentlich, wenn wir das nicht mehr haben? Und Google hatte früher äh gut reden, weil da konnten die eigentlich einfach alle Nutzer dadurch tracken und Nutzerinnen dadurch tracken, dass ja
ähm Google der Anfang vom Internet ist.
Und dann haben sie irgendwie solche äh Google Plus One und was nicht alles nur der Facebook Like Button und was nicht alles, ne? Und äh.
Wenn die aber also Google vor allem wenn du halt da weg bist und eine Seite verlässt, dann ähm dann haben die halt irgendwie, sind die halt nicht so glücklich. Und jetzt haben sie sich überlegt,
Ey, wir haben doch auch den den marktstärksten äh Browser. Lass uns doch mal überlegen, ob wir in denen ein Feature einbauen können.
Dass ja nicht ganz so schlimm ist wie Cookies, nicht ganz so schlimm, wo wir argumentieren können, dass es ein bisschen besser und ähm,
und dann können wir sagen, dann können wir im Prinzip sagen, dass wir den Cookie getötet haben für etwas, was was äh mehr Privacy Aware ist. Das scheint so ein bisschen das zu sein,
ne? Was Google mit diesem Flock äh vorhat. Und,
um das jetzt mal naiv zu oder so ein bisschen vereinfacht zu erklären, die Idee ist, dass sie das.
Die Anonymisierung des Tracking oder nicht die Anonymisierung, aber sagen wir mal die die Unschärfe des Tracking.
Auf dem auf der Browser in dem Browser schon machen, um dann nach draußen kein.
Identity basiertes Tracking mehr notwendig zu haben. Also früher, ne, jeder, jede Nutzerin kriegt ihr eigenen Cookie und die Tracker äh wissen, was die Nutzerinnen macht und errechnen dadurch, was die wohl.
Für Schuhe kaufen will.
Ja und jetzt, also es ist, sie wollen ja keine Tracking-ID, sondern sie wollen schon, das muss man immerhin sagen. Also sie wollen ein etwas ähm ein etwas besseres Modell machen. Also am Anfang
errechnest du ein Modell von. Also Kohorten sind einfach eine Reihe von Webbrowsern.
Ähnliche ähm kürzliche Browsing Browser Histories haben. Also ein ähnliches Verhalten. Ne, also du.
Du nimmst dir die du nimmst dir das Nutzerinnenverhalten von all deinen Browsern,
analysierst das, clusterst das und sagst, aha, wer wer sind denn hier ähnliche, ne? Und dann kannst du dir unendlich viele Kohorten daraus bauen, das kannst du in so einem Modell frei bestimmen, sagst du, mach mir da bitte zwei draus,
oder mach mir da so viele draus wie wir Nutzerinnen haben oder machen wir daraus halt hunderte, ne?
Da machst du natürlich so ein so ein Sweetspot ähm vielleicht so lange, wie du die wie die Quorten für dich noch Sinn machen. Jetzt.
Berechnet dein Browser auf deinem Gerät dieses Modell, also diese dieses Clustermodell und er rechnet für sich selber welcher Kohorte entspreche ich denn hier?
Und ähm,
dann sagt er dem einfach nur noch, ich bin übrigens aus der und der Cohorte. Statt zu sagen, ich bin die und die Person. Na, sie sagt, ich ähm,
Und die kohorte ist natürlich etwas diffuser, ja, das da ist nicht jede einzelne Seite drauf, die du besucht hast.
Oder draus erkennbar, aber du bist einer typisch einer, einer sehr,
gleichen Gruppe zugeordnet. Und ähm entsprechend ähm wird dir,
die Werbung für diese Zielgruppe angezeigt. Jetzt muss man dazu sagen, ne, die, die das Werbetracking machen, die haben ja auch diese Zielgruppen,
und die Idee, also vom Ansatz ist es jetzt einfach so, die Zielgruppenberechnung erfolgt schon mal in deinem Browser, damit du nicht ganz so viele Informationen an die Tracker geben musst, damit die die Zielgruppenberechnung machen können.
Das ist so vereinfacht erklärt was die vorhaben. So und jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, ach, das ist ja schön, ne, gegenüber dem.
Gegenüber dem dem Cookie-Tracking-Modell gibst du jetzt weniger Informationen an die Tracker ähm und und wirst so ein bisschen diffuser, ne? Du, du, du, du nimmst dir die Berechnung, zu welcher Gruppe du gehörst, schon mal ab.
Und da richtet sich jetzt sehr viel ähm Gegenwind gegen.
Von der IFF ähm von anderen Browserherstellern und äh Google ähm ja kriegt er.
Mit dieser Entwicklung in Chrome äh durchaus einiges an Kontra. Richtet sich, glaube ich, auch dagegen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Hast du jetzt schon gesagt, wie es heißt?
Nee, genau, Flock und äh Flock steht für Federated Learning of äh.
Heißt es, wobei es ein bisschen schwierig zu übersetzen ist, finde ich, so vom Gefühl her ist es mehr so ein verteiltes.
Ja äh verteilte Erkenntnisssammlung über Gruppen.
Würde ich es mal nennen, ja, um so mal so ein bisschen besser verständlich zu machen. Korten ist halt so ein so ein Begriff auch aus der aus der Statistik, ne, oder.
Ja, also mir ist der Begriff äh sehr bekannt. Ähm.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen, aber es lese kein kein Begriff, den einiges täglich äh benutzt, ne.
Geburtskohorte.
Nutzt doch keiner.
Ja, weil hast du nicht häufiger mit Geburtsgeburtsjahreskosten?
Schulklasse. Schulklasse.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube das letzte Mal, dass ich das Wort äh aktiv gehört habe, ist irgendwas mit Asterix oder so. Also.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist es so ihr.
Ansatzinformationen zu gewinnen, wo Leute eigentlich keine Informationen rausgeben wollen, aber dann gibt's doch etwas. Und du identifizierst dich zwar jetzt nicht unbedingt individuell.
Autoidentifizierst dich natürlich indirekt schon über deine Gruppe. Ja, also du
Und das ist ja eigentlich auch ein Problem bei Privacy, wo wir immer sagen, na ja, okay, hier, ne, nur so dieses, na, ich habe nichts zu verbergen, selbst wenn du nichts zu verbergen hast
dir können dann anhand weniger Merkmale kannst du schnell einer Gruppe zugeordnet werden und du weißt ja nicht, ob diese Gruppe unter Umständen auf irgendeine Art und Weise grade diskriminiert wird
und dann fällst du da halt rein, ja? SCHUFA irgendwie, wohnst du in der falschen Straße, ne? Also den gibt's einfach genug Beispiele,
und die technischen Ansätze, wie man quasi Informationen von Leuten gewinnt,
über die man eigentlich keine Informationen gewinnen möchte oder darf, ja, da gibt's ja auch noch andere, also es gibt ja auch dieses Konzept der differential Privacy zum Beispiel.
Was eher darauf passiert mit alle erzählen zwar irgendwas, aber alle Lügen
auch regelmäßig auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise, die sich dann aber letzten Endes beim Einsammeln dieser Information wieder so,
ausgleicht, dass du schon über die gesamte Gruppe eine relativ klare Aussage machen kannst, aber
nicht sicher über irgendeine Gruppe oder ein einzelnes Individuum, irgendetwas Konkretes sagen könntest, weil die Information auch genauso gut falsch gewesen sein konnte. Sie sind halt nur in ihrer äh,
Betrachtung über alles, kann man relativ klar wieder einschränken, was die richtige Gesamtinformation ist. Und das ist natürlich auch ein interessanter Ansatz, aber das ist nicht das, was ist.
Also ich würde schon sagen, also stellt euch flock vor, wie die.
Die Advertiser suchen nach Zielgruppen, ne, nicht und zwar natürlich sehr feinen Zielgruppen, Feingranulanzielgruppen, dafür gibt's auch genug Browser da draußen. Und du, die Idee ist, du berechnest deine Zielgruppe halt einfach schon mal vorher und sagst denen das.
Ne? Und damit ist es ein sinnvoller.
Eine eine sinnvolle Verteidigung oder eine sinnvolle Abschaffung von individualisiertem Profiling,
Und wenn du in einer Welt lebst, in der du sagst, individuell individualisiertes Profiling finde ich eine Katastrophe, aber zielgruppengerichtete Werbung finde ich super und ich empfinde es als eine großartige Idee, das in meinem Browser.
Ein zielgruppenberechnungstool schon mal drin ist, um den Trackern die Arbeit abzunehmen, dann könnte das eine Idee sein, die dich überzeugt. Aber.
Wenn du dich darum sorgst aufgrund der Zielgruppe, die wird dir aus dem Grund berechnet, zum Beispiel diskriminiert zu werden ähm
dann hast du im Zweifelsfall äh siehst du hier überhaupt keine Verbesserung der Welt, weil diese Tracker haben ja ohnehin nie,
auf dem individuellen Level gearbeitet, sondern immer mit den Gruppen. Es ist nur, dass du diese Gruppe halt denen jetzt schon mal kostenlos lieferst. Und.
Ähm alles, was wir von Cambridge Analyticer Skandalen und so weiter kennen, war da ging es immer um genau diese Kohortengruppen, die jetzt hier ähm demnächst eben von eurem Browser äh berechnet werden sollen.
Und das nennen sie halt Privacy Sandbox. Ähm dass sie halt sagen, ne, das ist der Teil, wir wir abstrahieren, das machen wir bei dir. Ähm,
Interessant wäre da natürlich auch, das sollte eigentlich auch eine ganze Reihe an ähm Experimenten ermöglichen.
Dass man halt mal einfach sich in eine andere äh Kohorte setzen kann. Aber ähm oder,
dass man hier einfach sagt, okay, nimm einfach jedes Mal eine andere. Ich möchte diese Tracker einfach nur durcheinander setzen. Aber das ist nicht der Kampf, der hier geführt wird, sondern der Kampf, der hier geführt wird, ist ja einfach mal der über äh einerseits die Zukunft des Webs,
und andererseits die Zukunft einer äh Milliarden äh Industrie für Zielgruppenorientierte Werbung. Und deswegen denke ich, werden wir das ähm.
Weiterhin äh hier oder in den nächsten Jahre äh ähm.
Wahrscheinlich begleiten diese Auseinandersetzung. Deswegen wollte ich dich schon mal so ein bisschen einleiten. Ohne vielleicht zum abschließenden Ergebnis zu kommen.
Derzeit gibt's das in Chrome, aber halt auch nur dort und die anderen Browserhersteller sagen eher so äh nee, brauchen wir nicht.
Ist das schon drin? Ich weiß nicht, ich nutze nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob's drinnen schon drin ist, aber ist auf jeden Fall soll's da rein. Der Rest will nicht.
Ja, da werden wir uns auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen mit auseinandersetzen. Ähm ich meine, da kann's nur Gewinner geben,
Flock ist natürlich auch echt ein schöner Name, ne? Weil die
Die Kampagnen-Webseite der IFF dagegen ist natürlich auch direkt, ne? Und äh Wortspiele mit ähm Forg äh bieten sich hier natürlich total an.
Okay, kann ich ja mal überprüfen, ob ich hier mit meinem Browser schon geflockt wäre oder nicht.
Also sie testen es gerade, also es ist sozusagen, bei manchen ist es drin und bei manchen äh ist es nicht drin und ich checke jetzt mal.
Ah, dann kann ich das so. Das machen wir jetzt noch. Das wird die Hörerin interessieren.
Ich bin gerade nicht geflockt hier.
Meiner auch nicht.
Hier ist die Rede von null Komma fünf Prozent aller Chrom User, also die Funktionalität ist drin, aber nicht für alle freigeschaltet.
Das ist auch schon,
Ich meine, ja, ich kenne das ja aus einer Perspektive von Google auch verstehen, ne, aber es ist natürlich schon krass, dass die sagen, ja, wir haben hier so ein neues Tracking-Feature, wir rollen das einfach mal beim halben Prozent der Nutzerinnen aus, machen wir so ein bisschen ab B-Test und so.
Und kommen dann eben zu so Erkenntnissen wie ey das ist fünfundneunzig Prozent so effektiv wie.
Ähm wie wie detailliertes Tracking. Voll geil, was wir hier tolles gebaut haben, ne? Also mit anderen Worten, das bringt dir überhaupt nichts, weil es also gegen das Tracking, weil es offenbar immer noch alle Informationen liefert, die die haben wollen.
Und das macht auch die Cookie-Sache dadurch, die ich einfacher, weil die müssen trotzdem noch irgendwie so überprüft werden. Es ist alles noch ein bisschen Elend. Und ich hoffe, dass das Web
als solches da äh in den nächsten Zeit auch mal wieder Standards macht, die einfach auch die Benutzung des selben wieder auf so ein Level stellen, wie man's ertragen kann, weil so geht's irgendwie gerade auch überhaupt nicht.
Permanent nervenden Webseiten, das macht mich wahnsinnig. Ein.
So, dann lass uns mal zum Ende kommen. Das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz zwei wurde beschlossen, dass TK Mock wurde beschlossen, das war klar. Gesetze werden immer beschlossen. Ähm damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung.
Alles beschlossen, womit wir diese Sendung beschließen.
Ja, schönen Gruß ans Internet und äh ja, die diese Anhörung im Ausschuss Digitale Agenda wird, glaube ich, sehr unterhaltsam.
Ähm allerdings wird hier, glaube ich, nicht live gestreamt, aber immerhin wenigstens im Nachhinein als Aufzeichnung verfügbar sein. Ähm ich äh,
bin sehr gespannt, weil sich äh Luca ja tatsächlich relativ ähm hemdsärmlig, aber auch erstaunlich ähm.
Unelegant äh gegen ja so die Kritik
verteidigt. Also sie haben jetzt zum Beispiel den siebensiebzig Privacy Forscherin entgegengehalten, dass äh Melanie Brinkmann gesagt hätte, die Luca-App wäre gut. Was in Ordnung.
Oh Mann.
Also das kann die ja sagen aus ihrer Perspektive, ne, aus ihrer das ist ja genau der Grund, warum man eine gesellschaftliche, wissenschaftliche Debatte haben will, wo, ne, dann irgendwie eine
Epidemologin sagen kann, pass mal auf, diese Daten wären ganz gut und dann eben
Forscher sagen können, hm, kann man ja vielleicht auch ein bisschen anders machen, ne? Äh und dann kriegt man eine CWA und dann sitzen da die Forscherin wieder, sagen, ja, aber wir sehen nicht, ob die funktioniert. Funktioniert übrigens ähm.
Enorm gut
Boah, Mist, das hätte ich gerne heute noch in der Sendung gehabt. Das nehme ich in die nächste Sendung mit ein. Gibt äh gibt endlich mal so richtig schöne Werte über die äh wie die Corona-Warn-App wirkt. Schalten sie auch nächstes Mal wieder ein, dann werde ich die nämlich nochmal zitieren.
Genau. Wenn wir hier wieder unsere, unser Gutmenschentum über euch ausbreiten.
Unser Gutmenschen, äh unser Themenfremdes Gutmenschentum.
Ja. Pseudo. Pseudomäßig. Wir sind so pseudomäßig, ey. Ist geil.
Alles klar, hau rein, Tim.
Pseudos, können wir eine neue Jugendkultur mitgründen, die Pseudos. Bis bald.
Tim gründet eine Jugendkultur.
Zeit, oder?